i thought we were done this
hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
now before we get into today's vlog i
want to pop in here to share my general
disclaimer and include a trigger warning
that i'm going to be talking about
medication depression anxiety and weight
gain so please feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey i also want to tell you about my
sponsor billbar so this is a very
serious video and i'm going to be
talking about some real raw serious
topics so not to diminish that but i
still gotta say that i lowkey love these
bars so i talk a little bit about my
changing appetite in this video and one
thing that has helped me so much is to
make sure that i'm including a source of
protein in my snacks and meals so bill
bars have been a staple for me because
the protein keeps me fuller longer and
they just taste so good okay i need a
little snack to like get me through the
emotion of this next video a little
pick-me-up is needed feel free to get
your own
i'm gonna go for a puff because today
feels like a puff day and this coconut
marshmallow puff
she's calling my name
oh
yeah
[Music]
i might be having a rough week but let
me tell you she's a good pick-me-up so
super yummy if i need like a little
something to tie me over or i love to
add them to oats or yogurt for more sea
cheating snack so if you want to check
out build bar for yourself use my promo
code abbiesharp15 to get 15 off of your
order okay back to the vlog okay so it's
only been a few days but
these are so far my symptoms uh
tmi as usual i've had pretty bad
diarrhea for like three days
i am nauseous as f i actually took a
pregnancy test because i was like um
just want to make sure but i feel super
sick like worse and pregnant sick and my
insomnia is worse which was kind of what
i expected because that is what i was
warned may happen but i'm on like a
quarter of the lowest possible dose so
once i start feeling better i can start
to increase
so i'm at 10 milligrams now um a few
days ago i was at just five and i will
say that i've noticed that i'm a little
i don't know happier and like brighter
and more optimistic
but my sleep is still
questionable
hence why i have like a frog in my
throat because i think i slept like i
don't know maybe four hours last night
on and off the other thing i noticed is
that my appetite is better and not like
i'm extra hungry as i was when i was
like breastfeeding and i just felt like
more ravenous but just like i
look forward to and enjoy food more and
i actually really like that because i
know when i had covered earlier on in
the year it totally wiped out my
appetite and it really never fully
recovered so i would get to lunchtime
and i would stare into the fridge and i
would be like
nothing really sounds good to me right
now so i don't know maybe i was somewhat
depressed and i didn't even notice it or
know that because i know that this drug
works as an antidepressant at lower
doses and as like an anti-anxiety
medication at higher doses so i might
still be hitting those kind of
anti-depression dosages but it's
actually really nice to look forward to
eating something again and like cooking
fun things and i know that for a lot of
people the big fear with ssris is
excessive weight gain i just can't make
myself worry about that right now
because i think if i do gain weight
eating what i need to eat at my
healthiest happiest state then it was
probably weight that i needed to gain so
yeah i am feeling
optimistic so i'm at 20 milligrams now
um but weird
is starting to happen
basically
the last few nights my sleep medication
that i've been taking for about nine
months now successfully just like
full-on stopped working i think i got
two and a half hours of sleep last night
and the problem with that aside from the
fact that i am just like a walking
talking zombie right now
when i'm
a little more irritable with the fam jam
than usual is that while i'm awake at
night i get ravenous and i'm not talking
like a normal kind of like slow
progressive building hunger i'm talking
like a i'm going to kill someone for a
sandwich in the middle of the night
blood sugar low type of hunger and the
only reason i can distinguish this is
because when i was doing ivf they put me
on metformin and because my blood sugar
levels were normal before i was put on
metformin they tanked and so i was
having these crazy lows in the middle of
the night and waking up incredibly
ravenous and unable to sleep from this
kind of biting
aggressive hunger so i have been
basically forcing myself to have these
pretty substantial snacks before bed
that i feel quite full afterwards like
sometimes i feel borderline almost sick
but i'm anxious about waking up hungry
so like last night i think i had um like
a big bowl of protein oatmeal with
berries and then another bowl of cottage
cheese and fruit and that was after like
a full meal that i just had maybe an
hour and a half before that and i still
woke up in the night hungry so now i'm
like sleeping with popcorn and
turkey jerky beside my bed every night
and driving my husband crazy chomping
while he's trying to sleep but yeah it's
getting very frustrating and also
probably not making my insomnia better
because i'm stressed about it now so at
this rate you know it's totally possible
likely that i will gain weight if i'm
eating a larger than what my body wants
to eat snack plus more food in the
middle of the night and i mean of course
it is scary for you to feel like your
body is changing and you have no control
over it and i know that i live in a
privileged body and i and i've never had
to experience uncontrolled weight gain
outside of like the context of pregnancy
when of course it's more socially
acceptable but it's hard you know it's
really hard when you work in media like
i do and you have to just accept and
expect the trolls to come after you and
to be commenting on your appearance
every single day so yeah like i'm i'm
definitely wrestling with these worries
right now but the situation is also not
good because it's obviously [ __ ] with
my sleep and that is just perpetuating
my anxiety and fear about sleep and also
it's not great for me to be eating in
the middle of the night for my sibo and
my digestion so that is fueling a whole
other layer of worry and anxiety it's a
big problem right now and i mean i want
to see this process through i knew it
would be a journey i know it might not
be a fun journey but i'm really really
feeling defeated right now update i
spoke to my doctor and apparently this
drug can sometimes cause hypoglycemia
and it's not super common but it can
happen so
my doctor suggested that i kind of weigh
myself about once a week to keep tabs
and i never
step on the scale outside of like
medical reasons so
trigger warning i'm gonna talk numbers
on a scale for a second but i was
actually surprised to see that i'm
basically the exact same weight like
exact same weight that i have been my
whole adult life outside of of course
pregnancy and i think a lot of people
who you know track what they eat very
meticulously and are always on or off
diets very often will see major
fluctuations in the number on the scale
but it's amazing how stable your weight
actually can be when you don't engage in
these dieting behaviors and i can
appreciate that a lot of people just
don't like the weight where they kind of
net out at but we do have research to
suggest that our body has a preferred
set point range that it just wants to be
at and they'll fight to be at obviously
i'm well aware that medication may
change that um but so far
no change that i'm aware of anyway the
doctor basically said to combat the lows
and their disruption to my sleep um we
may need to change my sleep medication
so
yay just like
throw another curve ball into this side
effect cocktail and let's just see where
we net out
i just think it's ironic that i started
this journey like terrified of taking
medication and now i'm just like
oh whatever and i've started this just
give me more give me more give me more
change that change that whatever my body
is just an experiment at this point and
it is scary
and here we go so my dave ego just like
crapped out on me just stopped working
i've been sleeping like two three hours
a night and up every half an hour um so
the doctor has switched me to something
called trazadone which is another sleep
medication and i just started it and
it's working better not perfect but
definitely better than the day vigo was
once it just like
stopped working the problem is is that
i'm having these extreme heart
palpitations like i can't catch my
breath and it's particularly bad when i
lay down to go to sleep like the moment
i lay down and i can feel my heart
against the mattress it's so extreme i
can't sleep obviously it's distracting
me and my doctor said that it's not
uncommon when you start a new medication
or a new protocol that you get this like
anticipatory anxiety and so i'm hoping
that this is a temporary thing because
obviously the sleep is not going to get
better if my heart is beating out of my
chest and i'm having those physical
sensations of anxiety okay so i just
realized i haven't really given you a
sibo saga update in a little while but
long story short it's going pretty well
um my bowel movements have finally kind
of regulated um my bloating has
stabilized and i haven't really noticed
uh any of the medications making
anything worse so that's great but i do
tend to regress um whenever i come off
the medication so basically i will come
off the medication or the supplements
and then the sibo symptoms will all come
back so my doctor and i decided that
essentially what we're gonna do is keep
me on a low dose of the antimicrobials
that i was just taking to eradicate the
hydrogen bacteria and that way it'll
kind of continuously weed out some of
the bacteria to prevent it from pooling
and causing another kind of sibo
incident ultimately what i decided was
it's way better and easier for me to
take a couple pills a day even if it's
indefinitely than having to start this
whole process of eradication all over
again so knock on wood that it's the end
of the sibo saga so i'm at the full dose
of the
anti-anxiety medication and a higher
than normal dose of
the sleep medication and i feel like i'm
just getting worse
the heart palpitations are like 24 7 now
i feel like my hands are constantly like
shaking in like a little like nervous
way and i it's almost like i have
butterflies in my stomach but all the
way up in my throat side note i've
basically lost my voice from lack of
sleep so that's great the nausea in the
morning when i take the medication first
thing is so bad still i mean i'm two
months into this drug and it takes like
four hours for it to go away it's
horrible i also don't really feel like
my anxiety is getting any better which
is so frustrating and in fact i feel
like the physical sensations of anxiety
in my body like the
the beating heart and my like watching
my fingers just like shake ever so
slightly it's actually making the
psychological anxiety worse it's
reinforcing the fact that i have anxiety
so i've been so nervous about this you
know heart palpitation situation i
actually went to my doctor today he did
a few tests because i really just want
to rule out that there wasn't anything
dangerous going on and the good news is
is that my heart rate is not dangerous
but it is irregular and when i spoke to
my psychiatrist about this he actually
mentioned that that's very common in
people that have um anxiety regardless
because the heart palpitation thing has
been so disruptive to my life and my
sleep i talked to my psychiatrist and he
actually suggested me a boarding mission
on the trazadone which seems to be the
culprit of this it's a trap abort we
never left it
and
basically going back to the dave ego and
because the davey go wasn't working for
me before he's suggesting that i'd go on
an even higher dose than what's normally
recommended so i guess i'm just like
gonna give that a go tonight but i don't
know
i feel like a [ __ ] guinea pig at this
point and like i don't know how much
longer i can do this
so
tonight was a total
disaster
um
i have my night garden my retainer
that's why i sound like i do um
i spoke to the psychiatrist as well and
so he suggested i try to take it on an
off
off label
dosage um at like a higher dosage than
what is recommended so i did that last
night and i fell asleep really fast
because davido does that but
sorry
my hand's dying
um
but i
was up several times basically like
every sleep cycle probably every 30 to
40 minutes and then by 1 30
i was up and i just like could not get
back to sleep i was like this is it i've
been laying in bed for the past
hour and a half two hours trying to get
back to sleep but that's really bad
sleep hygiene so i just decided yep
that's my night that's why that's what i
got
and
um
i'm watching the hills in the basement
here
trashy
tv um
and kind of doing a walking meditation
i'm just like walking at 1.5 miles per
hour to just kind of reset my body which
is something i will sometimes do if i'm
having
physical anxiety i find that the
slow walk just kind of helps me
re-regulate my breathing and start again
so
it's my night
but i'm a woman i'm a mom and and i know
that from lots of experience
that i can rally on far less sleep so
excuse me what it's going to be
so
this is pretty much my worst
fear at this point um the day vigo just
like
doesn't work at all for me so absolutely
no hope in ever going back on that again
great cross that one off the list so now
the doctor's recommending that i go back
on the tracidone which caused me the
heart palpitations and to deal with the
heart palpitations he's prescribed
propranolol so basically i'm just taking
a drug that has a bad side effect and
more drugs to deal with those side
effects and now i'm feeling
scared basically i'm just layering drugs
upon drugs and just discarding them when
they just no longer work anymore because
i'm just using so much so now my whole
body shakes all day long my brain
doesn't feel tired when i'm laying in
bed despite severe sleep deprivation and
me not being able to
function in the day and i'm taking a
million pills
i feel like i'm in this dark tunnel
where i can't yet see the light but i
know that only glimmer of hope like the
only chance that i have is i have to
trudge forward there's there's no going
back i can't just quit and i know i'm
strong like i know that i've lived
through legitimate hell with ivf and
pregnancy and breastfeeding and this
whole sibo saga and this is just one
more cross to bear but
i guess i'm just really losing steam so
i just got back from a little weekend
trip with my hubby in chicago and i've
been on the antidepressants for the full
dose for about four weeks now and i want
to share some like teeny tiny little
indicators that i've picked up on that
tell me that it might actually be
starting to work so for one
i have not bit my nails look at this
that one look how long that is it's a
little crooked but it's long for me i've
been biting my nails chronically since i
was a little girl it's just one of my
many kind of anxious habits even with
shellac on my nails basically after a
week i start to get antsy and i just
bite them all off so the fact that i've
been able to kind of
maintain a manicure for two weeks
is a really good sign uh number two
is while i was in chicago basically like
the first day i was there i got backed
up tmi um and that basically always
happens when i travel and i almost
always freak the [ __ ] out basically i
start spiraling and i start to worry
like oh my gosh my sibo is gonna come
back and i'm never gonna get back on
track and my ibs is going to be horrible
for the rest of my life and usually my
height and anxiety actually just makes
things worse but
basically somehow
this weekend i kind of forgot about it
and then the next day it was just like
all good back on track so yeah that was
like
huge um and the other thing is i also am
finding that i'm not getting as stressed
out about having a bad night of sleep so
yeah that's still happening about every
two to three nights but i don't find
that i'm getting like as
pouty or angry about it my mindset's
essentially just going from like oh my
god my weekend's ruined this is the
worst situation ever
to
something more like well you know i
guess i'll just operate at a slightly
lower energy level than normal so yeah
it seems like some of my kind of
obsessive compulsions are starting to
soften which is amazing oh and last week
my husband asked me if i'd like to go to
a spontaneous lunch in the middle of the
work week day
and i was just like sure and my husband
said that he was like jaw to the floor
shocked
i mean i'm shocked old abby would never
be able to just like drop what i was
doing in the middle of the work week and
play hooky without substantial planning
and kind of self negotiation in my head
about it now my sleep is still like
pretty hidden this so last night i
actually had a pretty rough night
because i was like ruminating and
stressing over feeling a little pinched
on time with
so many new work ventures i've got in
the works plus kind of being up against
the clock with a lot of family vacations
and the holidays and you know weddings
and travel commitments etc so yeah i was
ruminating over that
all night so maybe i just need a little
more time to kind of mellow out about
things like that but also
i don't even know if that's a reasonable
expectation for this like maybe it's
totally normal to feel stressed and
overwhelmed when you're feeling a little
overworked or like you're burning the
candle at both ends yeah for those of
you guys at home who have taken
antidepressants or anti-anxiety
medication please let me know if it's
something that you still stress over
when you're feeling like tight on time
or deadlines or work stress etc so yeah
i don't even know what i should be
expecting from this process i i probably
can't expect to become like a whole new
appy but maybe just a better abby a
chiller abby a like better sleeping abby
you know i
feel like i mentioned this in my last
mental health vlog but i
definitely have an addictive personality
and ironically i feel like this whole
kind of
journey has
really reinforced that as i'm starting
to feel better on this medication i can
feel my brain starting to move in the
direction of like oh if 40 milligrams
makes me feel good then 60 milligrams
will make me feel great
and that my friends is
five shades of [ __ ] up i am so
grateful that i've got a really great
relationship with my psychiatrist and i
speak to him every wednesday so i really
feel like i have someone who can like
hold my hand throughout this process
because while i'm not a psychiatrist i
feel like with everything else in life
there is definitely too much of a good
thing as for other side effects i'm sure
you're going to ask have i gained weight
well maybe like a pound or two i only
weighed myself once uh because my doctor
suggested i try that um and like that
could have been completely insignificant
because i don't really have like a ton
of data to base it off of and like i
tell you guys all the time weight goes
up and down like five pounds depending
on the week or day but i will say that
my hunger has seemed to regulate pretty
well i'm not waking up in the middle of
the night ravenously hungry and having
like hypoglycemic attacks and there
really haven't been any major gi
disturbances and i want to acknowledge
that while i personally feel like
gaining a bit of weight is a fair
trade-off for
better mental health i also feel that
you know feeling out of touch with your
body or you know out of place in your
body can definitely be kind of anxiety
provoking and triggering for a lot of
people which i'm sure does not help the
recovery process so i'm not sure if my
experience would have been different if
i hadn't done the genetics test and i
went with like an ssri that was flagged
as being more likely to cause side
effects for me but at least for now i am
feeling like myself in my usual body um
but maybe just like a little more chill
there we are again it's 4 20
in the morning which wouldn't be so bad
if i haven't been up since 1. so
i'm really tired i'm already sick the
doctor prescribed me an even stronger
sleep medication last night and it
didn't even work so
i feel really helpless
i thought we were done this
you